good morning good morning good morning
everybody happy tuesday morning it's
time for gratitude journal live stream
number 22 coming at you we do this every
weekday I should be doing every day but
we do this every weekday to express
three things that we're grateful for
because as an entrepreneur you know how
hard it is to get up every day and go
into your business you may not be seeing
the results that you won't get but being
equally hungry for what you want to go
and chase and grateful for what you
already have is super important I switch
my camera there there we go frame it
better and so the two key things that we
do is as daily it's consistent it's it's
consistent right just like motivation
and inspiration and brushing your teeth
daily and then also that you asked
yourself why that you spend a little bit
of time reflecting on what it is that
you're grateful for and why if you
really want to feel the benefits then
you have to go one layer deeper beyond
just listen things off so how this works
I'm going to share three things I'm
grateful for you guys in a live chat
share three things you're grateful for
and i'll give you some shoutouts in a
couple minutes and then for those you're
watching the replays if you're down in
the comments below don't just lurk take
action do it consistently every day you
could do it with me do it on your own
just make sure it's getting done so for
me I'm I'm grateful for the end of long
weekends uh I I'm not a fan along
weekends I don't like long weekends it I
mean I recognize the benefit of it I
love being able to spend more time with
with the people around me but I hate
missing out on this I hate missing out
on work I love what I do so much that I
never look forward to long weekends
coming up to me it's like I was getting
into a conversation with somebody who's
a long weekend I get to sleep in and I
don't have to go to my job and if you
don't like your job to me this like this
work
with you guys helping entrepreneurs it's
oxygen for me it's like going a day
without air you know what's going to do
without food it's a it's a fast hate it
but you know I do like the time that I
got to spend doing other stuff but man
if you're doing work that that you don't
look forward to doing daily you got to
go do something else not that every day
is amazing but if you don't look forward
to the work that you're doing daily you
have to go do something else and so I
look forward to doing this daily doing
what I do daily you might look at my
schedule and say this is nuts I can
never do that that's okay you do yours
right I should look at your schedule and
feel like man that's crazy how's how's
that person who want to work I can't do
I couldn't do that anyway so I'm good
for the end of long weekends I'm
grateful for being back in the saddle
regular time stay full of work coming up
um I'm beautiful for a new ritual that
Nina and I started maybe about a month
ago we're on the weekend we usually have
breakfast at Tim Hortons on the Saturday
or the sunday and what we'll do is we'll
bring a book uh some kind of
relationship book and will read you know
half a chapter to a chapter of it over
breakfast together and right now we're
starting with the classic of the men are
from Mars Women for Venus and honestly
most of the the stuff in the book isn't
hyper relevant to us but the best part
that I pulled from it is not so much the
content of the book but the discussion
afterwards so we read half a chapter
then talk about it and just having that
opportunity to connect at a deeper level
and understand you know my wife better
and what's on her mind what she's
thinking about I think it's I think it's
uh I think for anybody in a relationship
I think I should be a like go to must
must do recommend the thing once a week
to sit down and read some kind of
relationship book together and then talk
about it
anyway we've we've gotten huge value
from it if anything just getting to know
each other even better and I always feel
great coming out of those conversations
so I'm super grateful for that we came
up with that idea I don't know where it
came from but that we started I'm happy
and then number three number three
number three I'm gonna go with tyrese
gibson i love you guys know Tyrese
Gibson he was I know him as the actor
from Fast and Furious one of the actors
in the Fast and Furious I didn't really
know much about him we are now working
on his top ten rules for success we did
a special earlier this is probably the
most time I've spent on the top ten I
don't want to say ever but in a long
time uh he has a lot of really
interesting points that he makes and he
says it in a different way than most
people and so it takes a lot of care and
consideration on the editing side to
find the material and so it's a ton of
work it's a ton of work I'm so far
behind on the top tens this week because
of Tyrese Gibson but it's awesome
because when it drops I know it's going
to be pretty special amazing so I'm
grateful for that so that's it for me
I'm people for the end of long weekends
i'm given from my weekend ritual and I'm
grateful for Tyrese Gibson's knowledge
let's get to you guys what are you
grateful for we've got a couple minutes
would have got Jay rise is doing the
shadowed already in the live chat but
you before I appreciate that Jay he is
grateful for youth kids and future
generations I love it always thinking
meta that Jay rise for engineers and
technology for artists and musicians for
models designers and fashion for chefs
and for photographers all massively
important so deeply thankful for all
creatives who live there art 11
entrepreneurs to I'm live in my art go
live yours novel grateful for another
day for the rain and for new business
opportunities I love that relax and
sleep station hey gang welcome aboard
Rishi Cup TV grateful for the every
opportunity that shows us to pursue our
dreams no matter how small google for
the five deer i saw on my run yesterday
pretty cool i hope you snap that up free
she grateful for heat electricity and
running water I love it I take running
water for granted every day relax and
sleep station I'm grateful for my first
opportunity to be on the gratitude live
stream with you are welcome aboard this
is awesome for the opportunity to learn
something new in my business and then
make it part of my toolbox and grateful
for this community I'm massively
grateful for this community to believe
nation Roxanne what else we got oh
there's a YouTube skip there's youtube
skip alright alright alright alright
there's some chatter some chatter
there's some chatter good day everyone
sky's the limit welcome back que el bien
I'm grateful for number one this amazing
cup of la lleva coffee I'm drinking
reach is going to be excited by that too
for quiet morning so that I can hear the
birds chirp cool and three run the Byron
Byron Byron burn for creating her
amazing books specifically the magic
Roger Rhonda Byrne think it's burned I
could be way off much good morning y'all
welcome back much else we got I got some
of I got some sleep last night but
before that I love it what do we have we
have Adrian good morning grateful for
warm fuzzy socks in Tuesday's the
grateful for Tuesday's I love it look at
Villa when people hate their jobs and
are looking for the weekends very sad
you know it super sad that's that's
ninety five percent of of the world that
sucks much as people i get to create my
own job my own work 11 ray hello
everyone welcome ray new feature builder
I'm with you Evan I'm not loving like
weekends as much anymore her what else
what else been to Montreal once Tim
Hortons is amazing those are you I know
they're in the it's starting to pop up
in the US but Tim Hortons is a weekly
ritual something that I highly recommend
maha vailo bootiful for stephen king
books have him read the stephen king
book sent
car fame but I love that you love it
what else people liking the tie resets
press oh yeah go check that out that's
pretty special it's also the start of my
clapping with the the answer Preston so
check that at nine ten guys that's it
that's the end Rishi Cup tbj rise and I
are about to head over to twitch play a
game of League of Legends while we
answer business questions to go check
that out if this is the last time I see
you today then go off and crush it have
an amazing day do your gratitude
tomorrow hopefully i'll see you here 9
a.m. eastern continue to believe this
way i believe or whatever your one word
is and i'll see you soon